Speaker 1: let's go to Roman
from Pittsburgh. Roman, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How are you?
Speaker 1: Good, good. I have to ask,
are you Ukrainian or Russian by chance?
Speaker 2: You know, it's funny. I moved
to Cleveland and there's a lot of
Eastern Europeans around this part,
and I'm Italian. Wow. There's a sandwich. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know what's so funny about. I've
never. You would. There's lots of people
who are not familiar with the name Roman.
And when you tell them my name is Roman, they
go, That must be because you're Italian. And I've
never met anyone with that name who's actually
Italian. They're always Russian or Ukrainian, but
you actually are Italian. And your name is Roman?
Speaker 2: Yeah, ironically, it's my parents
favorite chapter in the Bible, but I just there's
a there's a sandwich shop around here that makes a
Roman burger. So I joke that, you know,
they just were hungry when they were
pregnant when my mom was pregnant, so.
Speaker 1: Fair enough. All right. Well,
what's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Well, I just wanted to
comment. I'm an ultrasound tech or a sonographer,
depending on how fancy you want to be. Okay. And,
you know, I have a lot of history scanning, early
pregnancy, so seeing all of these bills pass, it's
very frustrating to see these people who
obviously have no medical background trying to,
you know, make any assessment on, you know, Roe
v Wade or anything like that. It's it's very
frustrating. Most of the people I do ultrasounds
with have no idea that they're pregnant. So yeah.
Speaker 1: And I think I think this is
interesting. There's two there's two sides to
this, right? One side of it is you often will
have a panel of like 870 year old men saying,
we decide what's legal and abortion and all this,
you know, object, OB care and all these different
stuff. That makes absolutely no sense. Also,
I think sometimes when we take this too far,
we get into this stuff where like during the
Iraq war, you had a lot of right wingers going,
if you haven't been in the military, you can't
have an opinion about this war. And it's like,
no, you can actually actually you can. So
I think we want to balance both sides of
this. But your point is very well taken.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it's it's just one of those
things where the medicine is like, you know,
really messy. And, like, I think like even
Joe Rogan, when he talks about it, he's like, oh,
I'm pro-life or sorry, pro-choice, but he's like,
it kind of gets really messy when you talk about
like late term abortions. And I think that people
really get mired in those details. And like 80% of
abortions occur like less before 12 weeks. Yeah,
like a quarter of pregnancies end before people
even realize that they're pregnant. Yep. So I
feel like there's a lot of misunderstanding of
when abortions happen and, like, why they happen.
Like. Like, just look, I mean, I'm not going
to tell people to look up in some of these
complex medical things, but like hydrocephalus,
like some, like it's not a viable thing. Like,
I don't think that it makes sense to make someone
carry a baby that doesn't have a brain to full
term. But I mean, what are you going to do?
Speaker 1: One of the other things that's often
mentioned in this discussion is the right wingers
will say, you know, you it's crazy that you can
walk in at eight and a half months pregnant and
say abort. And when you actually talk to OB-GYNs,
they almost universally say, number one, never
happens once you're eight and a half. If you're if
you're given a due date at 40 weeks and it's two
weeks before that, and you walk in and you go, I'd
like to abort. First of all, OB-GYNs say it never
happens. Number two, they almost exclusively say,
I also wouldn't do it at that point. You go,
wait a second. Yeah. There's no medical condition
threatening your life. No. Well. So why. Why
would we do that? Let's talk about adoption. Let's
OB-GYN say that's an imaginary situation.
Speaker 2: You know, I mean, even at like
24 weeks, you can at least, like, you know,
stabilize a pregnancy. But before that,
I mean, like, it's it's not even a conversation.
Speaker 1: Hey, real quick, I'm curious because
you so you're in a situation where you're doing
the ultrasounds for women who they may not even
know they're pregnant. So why are they getting
jail for sound if they don't do? What's the
circumstance of them getting an ultrasound?
Speaker 2: Yeah. So, I mean, we do a lot of
different ultrasounds. I'm a what they call
a general ultrasound tech. They're like other
ultrasound techs who specialize in only doing OB.
Okay I personally like the late term stuff is it
gets I feel bad a lot of times for those those
people who only work in my firm because a lot
of times they are scanning women who either have
you know, they're at risk for some reason because,
you know, they're they're most likely to come
back for like follow ups, do scans. So that's
maternal diabetes, slash obesity, drug use. Twins
makes you automatically at risk some sort of
prior history of of complication. Sure.
For me, it's they come in through the E.R.
and then they have some sort of indication
either pain, bleeding. They they came in with
a positive pregnancy test and they had some
sort of prior ultrasound. And so, you know,
sometimes they come in to like get a follow up. I
don't recommend that coming in through the E.R.,
especially if you're coming in from a different
hospital system. We won't have that history.
Sure. And, you know, it's very rare that this
happens, but just, you know, want to put this
out there. Do not come to try to get pictures. If
you're coming in through the E.R., we we can't let
you take pictures of the screen. It's like a legal
issue. And like we don't have a printer because
we're not designed to do this, you know, now.
Speaker 1: Because you're attack. You're not
delivering the news, okay? You're pregnant, right?
You're doing the scanning. And then a doctor says,
hey, this shows that you're pregnant.
Speaker 2: Yeah, we we write
like a short little a set, like they
call it like a tech assessment. Yep.
And then the radiologist can either agree or
disagree with our assessment. I keep my mouth
shut, and personally, I kind of like that the
liability is not something I want. And like,
I only needed, you know, to support two years
of schooling that ten years and $100,000
worth it. That just does not seem worth, you know?
Speaker 1: I gotcha. I gotcha. All right. Well,
listen, I appreciate you sharing
about this super interesting.
Speaker 2: Can I ask you a really quick
question? Yeah, go ahead. Do you think
it's good for Democrats if Ron DeSantis runs?
Speaker 1: Too early to say. Depends who he's
running against. I know. I know the
point of the question, which is like,
is he is he a better or more difficult candidate
to defeat? I just think we don't know until
we know who the Democratic nominee is.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I thought maybe if he ran
against Trump that it might cause, like, almost
a slip split ticket, like a blow in the primary.
Speaker 1: That's another question
that you're just too early to say.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm. All right. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so much.
Appreciate the call. Very, very
interesting, I have to tell you